اي صناعه تقوم يعني اساسها المعرفه وليس
اساسها الاتجاه صحيح الموجه التواصل او
موجه المشاهير اعتبرها مثل دوره حياه
اليرقات
يعني لا يمكن يظهر ممثل ممتاز من خلال
الوسائط ولا يمكن يظهر صحفي ممتاز ولا
يمكن يظهر مصور ممتاز هي تجي لمحات تعجب
كانك تعجب في مجلس ثم ينتهي تنتهي القصه
عمرهم قصير جدا مهما كان سنه سنتين ثلاثه
والدوره سريعه بس لا تخلق اساس ولا تخلق
تنمي والمقابل هي تخلق الفراغ المعرفي
المهول ويعني لنقل انه حاله من حالات يعني
همم رغوه معينه
تذهب فبالتالي في الخطوره على اي مجتمع
ليست فقط في الصناعه الخطوره في حاله
غيابها المهنيه هذه ستدي الحالات المتغيره
والمتقلبه
واضعف الوعي معك همم حاله يعني التنقل
السريع وغياب القدره بالتالي انت تصبح
يعني عرضها للتحدي
وعرضها للهيمنه من قبل وسائل اخرى نتيجه
هذا الفراغ لانك لم
تغذيتها ليست فقط على الصناعه يمكن خطوره
تعريفيا هؤلاء ايضا عرضه للاستقطاب
والتجنيد سواء هو صاحب اجنده يعني عنده
جنده سياسيه او هو بسيط مغفل لا يدري كيف
كيف تدور الامور والصراعات فممكن يصير
العرضه للاغراء المالي عرضه للاغراء
السياسي
استثمرهم اعلاميا مالهم الجهاد ذات الكسب
السريع يعني اكثر الجهات التي تتعامل مع
هذه الفئات جهات توزع منتجات توزع بطاقات
تعرض السلع للبيع لكن لا تقدم معرفه